Hey it's me Destin. Ahh.. I got my
dad a present for father's day, and it's kind of weird, so I figured
I'd show you an interesting principle with the present.
It's a chicken. I got my dad a chicken
for father's day, and I want to show you a pretty interesting method
that chickens have to keep their heads stable. You know in guidance and control you have
feedback loops and so you have to know your position, and
where your relative motion is going so you can compensate for it, but chickens are really good
at this, so I'll show you.. Watch his head stay totally stationary
as I move his body.
I can move his body in pretty much any direction and his head stays
rock solid in one position.
This is really hard to do. So anyway, he knows exactly
where his body is and where his body's moving.
It's kinda fun to watch isn't it. So, they're really good at it
I don't really know why, but I'm sure there's an explanation
There's my sister Browley with the other
chicken we got dad, so..
(Sister) Mine does tail tricks. Up down, up, down.
-Anyway,
look how solid his head is.
That's kinda stupid, he'd probably peck me in the eye
so I'll stop now. Alright, so bye.
(Dad) The perfect father's day gift.
- Yep, he liked it.
[angry chicken sounds]